[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم لما كان عندي
معالي الدكتور علي الدين هلال استاذ
العلوم السياسيه البارز منذ حوالي شهر
وطرحت عليه امام حضراتكم سؤالا كيف يمكن
لصراخ غزه ان يشكل الشرق الاوسط هذا ما
قاله وعدد من السياسيين والمراقبين ومن
بينهم الدكتور علي الدين هلال نفسه اجابني
لست من الغافلين حتى اقفز الى اي
استنتاجات ما زال الوقت مبكر مر شهر وها
انا اطر عليه نفس السؤال امام حضراتكم
مساء الخير معال الدكتور مساء النور يا
استاذ سيد السؤال اللي شغل الناس كثيرا
جدا الصراع في غزه مازال يعني بيتشكل
امامنا وتجاذبات كتيره في الاقليم وخارج
الاقليم حضرتك شايف الشهور المقبله يمكن
ان تسفر عن
ايه اولا يعني شكرا على
الدعوه وبرضو هبدا يعني لازم ابدا واقول
اي اجابه لا يمكن اعتبارها اجابه علميه
بالمعنى الدقيق هو نوع من
الاستشراف احنا مازلنا في وسط
حرب حرب استمرت 49 يوم الهدنه
انسانيه س ايام ثم استرف الحرب عوده الى
الحرب ولا نعرف قد حتستمر احنا بنسجل
الحلقه معال الدكتور يوم 4 ديسمبر
2023 ماش لا نعرف الى مذا حتستمر
احنا اذا المفتاح المفتاح الاجابه على
السؤال الناحيه العلميه قد ايه الحرب و
على اي توازن قوه سوف
تنتهي ثلاثه ايه مواقف الاطراف المختلفه
يبقى احنا رقم واحد في معادله التقييييم
الى اي مدى
[موسيقى]
تستمر قدرات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حماس او غير حماس من الواضح ان
هم استعدوا لهذه المعركه
وخزنه سلاح وزخائر
ووقود انا كنت بمع النهارده او امبارح
لحوار لامين اللجنه المركزيه لمنظمه
التحرير وقال تعبير يعني
انا وجد تعبير حكيم قال طبعا في بساله
فلسطينيه وفي جراه فلسطينيه وفي تصميم على
الارض لكن من الخطا الباله تصور
الفلسطينيين سوبر
هيوم او ان عندهم قدرات خارقه
خارقه في
النهايه السلاح اذا ل مدد
بيخلص اخزم في
الاعتبار عدم التفاوت عدم المساواه عدم
التكافؤ عدم التكافؤ بين القدرات
الاسرائيليه جيش
جرار ولما بتزيني امريكا بتزوده لما اتقال
بقى حكايه انفاق امريكا زوتم
بكميه من قنابل خصيصا لدك الانفاق
والاختراق الحواجز الفولاذيه
والحديديه
ا وانا بعتبر ان امريكا شريك في الحرب مش
مدعم شريك في
الحرب
بالمستشارين
بالمعلومات بالاسلحه والزخائر
تقديم النصائح ما يعني ان الحرب ما بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه والولايات المتحده
واسرائيل وداعميهم وداعميهم يعني الحاجه
اللي ما عملهاش ارسال جنود مقاتلين اه
انما ارسلت
مستشارين للمساعده وابداء الراي وتقديم
النصيحه
طيب السؤ ادي الطرف الاول المعادله الطرف
الفلسطيني الطرف الثاني
المباشر الطرف الاسرائيلي قد ايه اسرائيل
تستطيع تستمر في الحرب اذا وصل لها من
الزاويه الحربيه القتاليه لا فيش
مشكله تستطيع يستطيع الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو جيش مدرب وكذا وكذا انه
يستمر ذخائر افراد احتياطي
ال انما قد ايه سياسيا يقدر
يستمر بالنظر الى عده
عوامل الاول الضغوط جوه
اسرائيل انت عندك لغايه النهارده وامبارح
مظاهرات
حاشده في للبرلمان لبيت رئيس الوزراء
بيقوله انت تضحي بارواح
الجنود
المحتجزين انت حرصك على عمل نصر تبرق بيه
وجهك او تبيض بيه
صورتك بتعمل ده وبتهد حياه اي كان عدد
المحتجزين اين ضغوط الراي العام الدولي
يعني دلوقتي عدد اكبر من الدول الغربيه
انا مش بتكلم على الدول اللي واخده موقف
مؤيد لفلسطين الصين
روسيا اغلب
الدول الاسيويه
والافريقيه اكلم عن الدول الغربيه
بدا انا عايز بس انقل الكلام
بامانه يعني بلينكن لما راح من ايام
بيقولهم ابيب بلينكن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي رحله الا ابيب يعني كان رسالته
ايه هم بيقولوا الحرب سوف تستمر شهورا هو
بيقول لهم ارجوك خليها
اسابيع ههم شهور للاسرائيليين عاوزين شهور
شهور يا امريكا ادينا
فرصه طلعش نا قرارات خدي موقف
ناح بلينكن بيقوله انه كذا خليها اسب
ا باليقين لما بنقرا تصريحات رؤساء الدول
رؤساء الوزارات في الدول الغربيه يعني في
دول الحلف الاطلنطي كذا
نغمه التاكيد على حمايه المدنيين زادت
دائره الصراع دلوقتي في دائره
مباشره
على ارض
غزه اللي هي الفلسطينيين
واسرائيل في دائره تانيه اللي هي شمال غزه
والي هي حزب الله شمال شمال اسرائيل شمال
اسرائيل عفوا شمال اسرائيل اللي هو حزب
الله ودي مشتعله
وبتزيد في دائره ثالثه
اللي هي العراق سوريا اليمن في الثلاث
بلاد دول في يعني في سوريا قذائف بتطلع
تضرب في مناطق اسرائيليه محدوده العدد لكن
موجوده لكن اعداد اكبر من محاولات ضرب
القواعد العسكريه في العراق امريكيه يعني
الامريكيه في العراق وامريكا ضربت من يوم
او من يومين في منطقه كركوك موقع هي زعمت
فيه ان ده كان بيعد ليه عمليه عسكريه ضد
امريكا ضد القاعده الامريكيه
ا من في الجنوب اليمن الحوثيين بيطلقوا
صواريخ صواريخ طبعا يجب نفهم ان الجبهه
الثالثه دي هي ايران ايران بالمعلومات
يعني مثلا يعني الاخوه في الحوثيين كده ما
عندهمش جهاز مخابراتي يسمح ان انت تعرف ان
في باخره جايه ورفع عالم اي بلد من البلاد
انك تقول ان الباخره دي يملكها اسرائيل
يعني دي معلومات الذي يملكها هو مخابرات
دوله متابعه حركه السفن في العالم الاخر
اذا انا بقول الجزء الاول استمرار القتال
قد ايه
هيستمر و هيتوقف ازاي على
الثلاث جبهات دول الجبهه المباشره في غزه
الجبهه الثانيه في شمال اسرائيل شما حزب
الله والجبهه بقى المسانده او كده اللي هي
العراق وسوريا و الجماعات المؤيده
والداعمه لايران
لايران
طيب يعني في السؤال التاني اللي
بيطرح اللي
هو ساعات يقولوا اليوم التالي اه بعد توقف
ال اه
مدافع
و انا لعلي ذكرت مع حضرتك كتاب شهير في
مصر
الفه استاذ محمد سيد احمد وسماه بعد ان
تسكت
المدافع او بعد ان تصم على الوضع في مصر
اه الكاتب السياسي المصري راحل وقال يا
اخوانا خدوا بالكم المدافع في يوم من
الايام
هتسكت ايا كان كان شكل اللي هتنتهي به هذا
الصمت او كده طيب ايه اللي مطروح
دلوقتي الاول كان اول مره احد مراكز
البحوث
الاسرائيليه طرح
كده ان في اربع سيناريوهات او خمس س
السيناريو
الاول كلهم مبنيين على فرض واحد القضاء
على حماس طب بعد كده بقى هو بيفت هذا ايه
واحد ان غزه تدار ب قوات من الامم المتحده
ان غزه تدار بقوات امريكيه وغربيه ان غزه
تدار بقوات
عربيه كله كلام يعني السم في العسل ولا
اعتقد في اي دوله عربيه هتقبل المشاركه في
حاجه زي
كده معناه انت
بتدير غزه مع افتراض الافتراض اللي هو
هزيمه حماس بتدخل
على اسنه الرماح
الاسرائيليه وانك جاي تنفذ سياسيا
واداريا ما لم ما لا تستطيع اسرائيل
القيام
به وبعض الاخوه الفلسطينيين قالوا هنتعامل
مع اي حد يجي يدير غزه على انها قوى
معاديه انها عناصر
معاديه طيب الم الاسرائيل برده مذبذب مره
يقولوا هنحتل غزه بس ده اقل
الاصوات مره
يقولوا حتى بعد ان تنتهي الحرب هيبقى لنا
السيطره الامنيه على غزه اه اه طب بس نقرا
الكلام ده طب هل هل استطيع ان انا احافظ
على سيطار امنيه على الارض من غير وجود
ارضي مستحيل ما احنا جربنا الاسفار
التكنولوجيه مظبوط كده اه فاذا ده يبقى
معناه انه هيقيم بعض المراكز العسكريه
في
داخل العم في خارج القطاع يعني او حوله او
حوله وهيبقى دوره ايه
امريكا
يعني كان في موقف متكامل لها في مقال كتبه
الرئيس بايدن في واشنطن بوست واشنطن بوست
يوم السبت
نوفمبر
طرح طبعا مبني على العداء
الكامل
لحماس وحماس يعني اسرائيل تقول ايه حماس
داعش يعني الربط في الذهن الغربي ان حماس
دي هي داعش
داعش
وحتى الرئيس بايدن المقال بتاعه اسمه ايه
امريكا لن تتراجع امام تحدي بوتين يعني
روسيا وحماس وحماس وربط ما بين
حماس
وبوتن وال من وجهه نظره اللي هي
منحازه اعتبر ان الحرب في اوكرانيا والحرب
في غزه
واحده وكتب بالنص هي حرب من اجل
الديمقراطيه والحريه واحترام الحريات
واحترام الافراد واحترام حقوق الانسان طب
الكلام يبده غريب
جدا في نفس المقاله يقول قلبي يتمزق على
الضحايا الفلسطينيين وكذا بس انا عايز بقى
خدوا بالكم حضرتك يعني حتى كثير من
الاصوات الغربيه تتعامل مع القضيه انها
موضوع انساني ناس غلايه بيموتوا عايزين
يبعت لهم مساعدات لا اه طب هو في الجزء ده
موجود انما لا دي قضيه سياسيه ده شعب عايز
حق تقير المصير ده شعب عايز يعيش في عدل
وكرا وحريه ف انك تحول الموضوع تماما الى
قضيه انسانيه
يعني حق يراد به
باطل في المقال ده وكرره بعد كده
بايتن يستخدم
تعبير سلطه
فلسطينيه
ريلاز ا بعد تخديد دمائها يعني بعد الدماع
ا سلطه فلسطينيه اكثر حيويه بس ماحدش يعني
ايه وهنا بقى في بقى مراكز البحوث و
بالعربي وبالانجليزي وبكل الدنيا يعني طب
هل يعني تعدي تغيير رئيس السلطه
الوطنيه جايب
حداني طيب طب الحد الثاني ده هيبقى على
هوا الشعب الفلسطيني على هواء اسرائيل ولا
احنا على هواء اسرايل يعني طب يعني هل هنا
هنا بق نقطه مهمه جدا من له حق الوصايه
على مستقبل شعب فلسطين بالنسبه لنا الشعب
الفلسطين ليس من حق اي طرف
اخر من واجبنا ا كدول عربيه كدول اسلاميه
نوجه
النصح لما بنقعد مع قاده فلسطينيين مع
مثقفين فلسطينيين احنا نقولوا يا اخوانا
احنا بنعت قد كذا لكن في النهايه القرار
حول مستقبل مش عايز اقول كلمه غزه بس لان
الحاح على كلمه غده غزه بتوقع في كمين
اسرائيلي اه الفصل بين غزه والضفه الغربيه
الضفه الغربيه الله وده وقع بالفعل وده دي
ده اسرائيل بتعمل على هذا من 30 سنه هي
هدف اسرائيل عميق الهوه بين حماس وفتح وفي
بعض
الاحيان حماس
كبرت يعني مش عايز اقول بمباركه اسرائيليه
بعلم اسرائيل هو لما كان السفير القطري
مشكورا ياخد شنطه فيها الاف وملين ال
دولارات ويدخل بها غزه ويسلمها وده كان
بعلم اسرائيل يعني اسرائيل كانت تعلم ان
في فلوس هتذهب الى الحكومه الفلسطينيه في
غزه ايه اللي بتها حماس للا وجدت في ده
مصلحه لها ان حماس ما بقاش معتمده اعتماد
كامل على رام الله في فتره خلافات
وبالتالي تظل الفرقه موجوده بين اطراف
الاطراف ال لذلك احنا عايزين يعني يعني
احنا كمثقفين و محلين عرب هنقول ايه يعني
مستقبل غزه او اداره غزه بعد الصراع في
اطار القضيه
الفلسطينيه لكن احنا مش هنعمل حل لغزه
يختلف عن المسار الذي نريده
ل الضفه الغربيه وده مسار واحد المسار هو
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله اذا
معالي الدكتور من العرض اللي حضرتك
عرضته بتؤكد فكره انه في ارتباك كبير كل
الاطراف الرئيسيه الاطراف الرئيسيه اللي
انا سمعتها من حضرتك هي الاطراف الامريكيه
الاطراف الاسرائيليه الاطراف العربيه يعني
يعني دورها ليس واضحا الا بتحديد مواقف
محدده يعني مجرد رفض او ادانه يعني و انه
الاطراف الفاعله الرئيسيه لولايات المتحده
واسرائيل مرتبكين فيما يجب ان يفعلوه في
حاله اصلا ان هم تمكنوا مما يعتقدوا انه
مسلم به وهو الاتصال على حماس وبالتالي كل
الامور تظل عالقه الى ان تفرض الوقائع
نفسها للاسف ده صحيح والعنصر الحاسم
استمرار المقاومه الفلسطينيه على البقاء
ذا استمر هذا الاستمرار بيخلي الراي العام
العربي والعالمي متجاوب مه هو صحيح يا
معالي
الدكتور اذا كان في اجابه للسؤال ان في
دول عربيه تتمنى ان تهزم حماس وتختفي
يعني لانه اسرائيل بتقول كده كتير يعني زي
ما ب قالت ان بعض الدول كانت تتمنى وباركت
يعني محاولتنا استئصال حزب الله في 2006
شوف اسرائيل لها ان تقول ما
تريد وده نوع
من تسميم
الفكري طب هل حضرتك نسيت ان هو يوم على
طول
سبعه 7 اكتوبر لانهم بيقولوا ده مصر ابلغت
اسرائيل بموعد
الضربه
الفلسطينيه ط كلام غير
صحيح
وبلغ بيه يعني الشطط يقوللك ده مدير
المخابرات المصريه كلم نتنياهو قبلها ب 10
ايام وقال له ده ف كذا طب هو لو كان ده
صحيح ما تنبو هما
ليه
الارجح اذا كان حصل حاجه كده احنا عندنا
تقارير من المخابرات
الاسرائيليه اخر شهرين والارجح انه تنبيه
نتنياهو انه استمرار في سياسه الاستيطان
الاستمرار في استفزاز
مشاعر الفلسطينيين سوف يؤدي الى انفجار
انا عايز اقول اسرائيل لن تترك
وسيله لتسميم العلاقات بين الفلسطين
والعرب لاحداث الفرقه
بين الفلسطينيين بعضهم البعض
الاخر تمييز مجموعه على مجموعه
لما تقول لك ده نص ده عدد العملاء بتوعنا
عدد العملاء المخابرات الاسرائيليه جوه
غزه لا لا حصر لهم انا بقول كل
دي
تسميم وغرس
للهزيمه ولو نفكر شويه ا هل لهم عملاء في
في غزه اه طبعا مساله عاديه يعني طبيعي
انما لو كان لهم هذا العدد الهائل من
عملاء كيف تسنى للفلسطينيين ان يقوموا بما
قاموا به يوم 7 اكتوبر يعني يعني اذا كان
مش عارف يقول لك المتحدث ايه المستمع ايه
وربنا ددانا عقل نفكر بيه ونقيم الامور ا
ايه هي ايه ايه الموضوع يعني ايه الاساس
في الكلام اللي حضرتك قلته دوت هي اصير
بتلعب على انه حماس اخوه المسلمين اه يعني
حسب حماس هي الف الفرع الفلسطيني من حركه
الاخوان المسلمين فضلا عن علاقتها بايران
وفضلا علاقتها بايران علاقتها بايران هي
علاقه سياسيه مش مذهبيه طبعا يعني في
اختلافات كذا في علاقه علاقه يعني سياسيه
علاقه تحالف سياسي لان حد الجزء الاكبر
ودلوقتي يعني الخليج الامارات السعوديه
على علاقات متطوره مع ايران افضل ولما
ودعي الرئيس الايراني
الى القمه
العربيه
الاسلاميه و نوهت بعض الصحف قالت اما
الوحيد اللي الاير محمد بن سلمان خرج من
القاع
الاستقبال يعني في يا الوحيد يا احد القله
ا يعني في عناصر ايجابيه في كذا انما هو
اللي بيخوف انه جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
لها مشاكل في عدد من الدول
العربيه ونصر هنا المسؤوليه تقع على قاده
حماس انا بتكلم بشفافيه جدا
يعني تاييد العرب لحماس على انها فصيل
فلسطيني يحارب من اجل حق تقرير المصير
للفلسطيني وفي هذا الامر وانا منهم نحن مع
حماس الى اخر
المتى فصيل فلسطيني فصيل وطني فلسطيني
يسعى الى تحرير فلسطين انا بقول ده
مسؤوليه قاده حماس وانه اذا حماس بتقدم
نفسها على انها فصيل وطني فلسطيني ينتمي
الى الفصائل الفلسطينيه المشتركه في هدف
واحد وهو تحرير فلسطين وتمكين الفلسطينين
من حقهم في تقير مصيرهم اعتقد ان غالبيه
العرب بما في هذا اغلب الدول العربيه
معها اذا هتتكلم في حاجات
ثانيه هيبقى هنا بقى في اه تتكلم على
اولوياتك باعتبار ان انت جماعه لها افكار
مختلفه تتحدث عن او انت بقى منظمه عالميه
ان انت فرع من تنظيم دولي ان لك
اهداف غير تحرير فلسين انا بعتقد برض
هيساعد جدا حضرتك الشراف المستقبل ا احنا
لسه ما عندناش عندنا مشكله ان حماس لم
تنضم بعد الى منظم التحرير الفلسطينيه اه
طبعا ومازال عندنا هذا الانقسام الانقسام
ده بيبقى خافت في اوقات الصراع زي دلوقتي
انما
هيبان واول حاجه اسرائيل هتقولها مع عمنا
تفاوض احنا عايزين نتكلم في السلام وبصور
برض انه في اد بيات حماس لابد يبقى واضح
هي عايزه ايه وهل هي ملتزمه باصله ولا لا
وهل هي ملتزمه باقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه الى جانب اسرائيل ولا لا بس كل
الاسئله دي تبقى مطروحه معالي الدكتور في
مرحله ما بعد ب اليوم التالي هيساعد على
هذا يعني حتى ا عشان ما هو اليوم التالي
ده لما هيجي هيبقى جاي زي القطر بقى
عاوزين اجابات عايزين اجابات يعني لابد
يبقى في تفكير طب ايه شكل وهذا هذا امر
يخص الفلسطينيين ايه شكل السلطه
الفلسطينيه وبرده يعني في يعني انتقادات
معينه ملاحظات معينه من جوه
الفلسطينيين كلما حسنا الاداء كلما يعني ا
دعمنا الوحده
الفلسطينيه ده هيساعدنا على اداره اليوم
التالي السؤال الاخير في اقل من نصف دقيقه
معال ددكتور دكتور عشان وقت حضرتك انا
مستمتع بالحديث يعني هل ما زلت ترى او
متمسك بانه تتوقع انه فرص تصعيد الصراع
محدوده وانه يظل محصورا في قطاع
غزه اعتقد
اه النهارده حضرتك او
امبارح وزير خارجيه سلطنه عمان سافر الى
طهران الارض كما تقول التقارير مع رساله
من الامريكان يعني لما بتقرا جيدا واضح ان
في قواعد
اشتباك متفق عليها وكان الاصل 5 كي متر من
ناحيه بالنسبه اسرائيل لبنان وانه وانه
هيدي جبه الاشد انا زي ما قلت كده حزب
الله اقوى من حماس 10
مرات ماكانش اكتر جيش جيش جيش يعني
حتى الان بتزداد
الوتيره منضبطه بما لا يمكن وصفها انها
شامله فيبدو لي حتى الان حتى الان ان في
تفاهما اساسا امريكي ايراني حول هذا الامر
وطبعا هتفضل دي الجبه الاكثر خطوره ما لم
تصر اسرائيل على مخططها بالتهجير بدفع
السكان الى الجنوب ف الجنوب بشكل قد يؤدي
الى مواجهه مع مصر هي اسرائيل اللي بتعمله
يقود الى هذا اه مواجهه مع مصر لكن هي
كلامها كله لا نحن لا نسعى نحن لا نسعى
وبنطلب الامم المتحده تجيع خيام في مناطق
كذا الى اخره علينا ان احنا نرقب الاحداث
مش يوم بيوم ساعه بساعه لان الحاجات دي
بتحدث مش فجاه كده يعني بتشوف عدد السكان
اللي انتقلوا الى منطقه معينه ايه الفرص
بتاعتهم هيروحوا فين الى اخره الخطر قائم
الخطر على ا على مصر من هذه الزاويه قائم
واعتقد انه يعني لو اسرائيل عملت كده
هيبقى ق انتهاك لاتفاقيه السلامه اللي
بينا وبينهم ان احنا المفروض الدولتين
ملتزمين بالحفاظ على سلامه وامن الحدود
اللي هم بيعملوه ده تهديد لسلامه
وامن الحدود
دلوقتي امريكا قررت كذا مره ان ضد هذا
الكلام ضد اي تهجير قصري بشكل
متكرر برجع اقول هل هو يعني لالهاء العرب
ل تنويم العرب ام انها تقصد
هذا الاجابه معلومات مش موجوده عندي يعني
ما هي المراسلات اللي النهارده بتتم بين
ملك
الاردن والامريكان بين الرئيس المصري
والامريكان ماذا تعهدت امريكا لمصر علنا
بيقولوا لن نسمح بهذا انما هنا بقى في
تحركات على الارض لننتظر ونرى معالي
الدكتور انا جزيل الشكر جزيل الشكر وممتن
لحضرتك انا اللي بشكرك انا اللي بشكرك
حضرتك عرضت الصوره اللي هي الضبابيه كما
هي الوضع ضبابي وكلنا علينا ان ننتظر لنرى
ما قد تسفر عنه هذه المحنه الكبيره يعني
وعدم التوسع في استنتاجات لا اساس لها من
الواقع جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور شكرا
جزيلا شكرا لحضراتكم وان شاء الله لمزيد
من الحلقات مع الدكتور علي الدين هلال في
قراءه المشهد المحلي الاقليمي الدولي الى
اللقاء